[Musik]
die schönsten ist
es ist so
[Musik]
ja
hey leute heute gibt es was herzhaftes
ich weiß ihr freundlich mal sehr wenn
ich euch herzhafte rezepte zeige und vor
allem wenn sie aus dem orient kommen
heute machen wir eine art ecke köpfte
das kennt ihr mit sicherheit alle dass
im burgund klöße mit hackfleisch
allerdings wird die kräfte traditionell
wie eine zitrone oder eier für mich
geformt und dann kippte auf arabische
wollen ja kein vernachlässigen in
manchen teilen sagt man auch kuppe also
da gibt es ganz viele verschiedene wird
dafür aber wir machen es halt ein
bisschen anders denn normalerweise witz
kritisiert dass man so teilchen aber wir
machen was heute in einer auflaufform
schonend im ofen und zwar nicht zitiert
mit unglaublich lecker netz sich
zuallererst mal die zutaten für den teig
wird bulgur nötig das ist kräftig trug
außerdem kartoffeln die habe ich bereits
gekocht und geschält hier habe ich
paprika marx zeitung kreuzkümmel 1 1 0
und wasser und für die füllung benötigen
die rinderhack salz und pfeffer olivenöl
rapsöl außerdem paprika markt paprika
flocken butter und zwiebeln
jetzt bereiten wir zuallererst den teig
so und es gibt verschiedene rezepte für
kippe also für ihre kräfte und da ist
meint eick wieder ein anderes rezept
also dieser teil ist wirklich nur für
dieses nische kräfte eben aus dem ofen
oder mit ihr bescheid ist an der stelle
und dieses rezept messe ich auch sehr
gerne in tasten ab aber für euch habe
ich natürlich abgewogen und schreibe
euch die gramm zahlen dahinter nämlich
immer so eine tasse und ich habe jetzt
hier 2000 bürger und eine tasse
kochendes wasser ist es kochend heiß und
das biest jetzt einfach drüber und dann
mache ich ein teller drüber und lasst
das ungefähr 15 minuten quellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und während unser bundes vor sich hin
quält machen wir hier am herd weiter ich
habe hier eine beschichtete pfanne und
gibt da jetzt ein neutrales öl rein und
darin bildet das hackfleisch richtig
schön krümelig angebraten so das gleiche
habe ich jetzt auch vor hitze schön
gewöhnlich eine frage und natürlich
gehen wir die gesetze dazu also salz
pfeffer und paprika blocken
die größte habe ich jetzt gut
untergerührt und als drittes gibt der
paprika mark dazu und paprika mag es
gibt noch mal so den krieg ich hin das
schmeckt unglaublich lecker
natürlich könnt ihr auf tomatenmark
nehmen aber ich würde euch wirklich zu
paprika magda so dass publisher markt
habe ich jetzt so ungefähr 30 bis 60
sekunden lang einarbeiten lassen so ein
bisschen angebraten jetzt schalte ich
den heraus und als nächstes gehen wir
unser olivenöl dazu dem tier gut ist
kaltgepresstes olivenöl und warum ich
das jetzt erst dazu gebe uni will dürfte
er nicht so stark erhitzen und das
hackfleisch das habe ich eben sehr stark
angebraten
es gebe ich jetzt noch einmal mit dazu
wo ihr das gut um und dann finden wir
das um in unserer schüsse
[Musik]
ich habe den gästen zu zeigen
ganz schlimm sein also er kommt also
olivenöl ist ja drin das habt ihr
gesehen haben sie macht auch mal fehler
ich habe das verzeihen werde alle meine
lieben jetzt wo wir unsere mutter zurück
in die pfanne
die fahnder die habe ich das gar nicht
ausgespielt wofür sparen wir uns auch im
schritt oder und die hat noch der spitze
es kann können wir den hut auch gern
wieder einschalten aber nur auf bittere
stufe damit die butter nicht anbrennt so
und jetzt gehen wir die zwiebel mit dazu
sicher schön fein geschnitten und falls
euch jetzt fragt warum hast du denn
dezibel nicht zusammen mit dem
hackfleisch angebraten die zwiebeln
werden auf mittlerer stufe angebraten
und das hackfleisch war immer vorstufe
und so kann man das eben besser regeln
und außerdem schränken wer jetzt die
zwiebeln auch schön in butter
damit sie schön den geschmack annehmen
jetzt habe ich die zwiebeln schön
langsam an dünsten lassen in der butter
auf mittlerer stufe wie gesagt schön
langsam vier minuten könnt ihr euch
dadurch zeit nehmen und man sagt ja auch
in den kochbüchern steht er immer wenn
die zwiebeln rosa sind
ich sehe an nie was rosen ist kennt ihr
das aus den kochbüchern
du siehst gold der fantasie also ich
sehe er so gelb bisher jedenfalls geben
wir das jetzt zum hackfleisch und hören
dass gut unter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so die füllung geben wir jetzt an die
seite und widmen uns dem teig wieder
denn ich hier unser boot ist jetzt
eigentlich so weit aber wir kümmern uns
ganz kurzen darum die kartoffeln
wichtig ist dass sie die kartoffeln
vorbereitet also einmal im wasser gar
kochen die schale entfernt
und jetzt zeige ich euch mit den
kartoffeln weitergeht in dem wir uns ist
ganz einfach eine gabel und zerdrücken
die
[Musik]
die kartoffeln die sind jetzt soweit
vorbereitet die gebe ich ganz kurz noch
eine seite und wenn man eine zweite mit
unserem bulgur der jetzt schon gefallen
ist und am besten kennt ihr diese
geriffelten bleche nicht zum töten gibt
es am besten und jetzt sowas falls nicht
dann einfach eure backform also eure
offenen form hauptsache ihr habt da
irgendwas flach ist wo er richtig schön
kleben können
denn in der schüssel jetzt nicht das
wird ein bisschen anstrengend man ist
verteidigt den ball einfach da drauf und
wenn wir das täglich wegrutschen giert
tue ich das ganz einfach ein tuch unten
drunter
so und jetzt beginnen wir und geben die
anderen zutaten rein das heißt einmal
kreuzkümmel den gemeinden und salz
einfach oben drüber geben und dann schon
mal anfangen langsam langsam alles gut
miteinander zu verbinden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rezepte gesehen paprika mag und das habe
ich auch das zugegeben und jetzt wird
einfach alles mit dem sauberen händen
richtig schön durchgeknetet
[Musik]
und es gibt hier so eine kleine
klebtechnik sage ich gerne und zwar
nimmt dich hier diese innenflächen von
der hand und drückt ihr ganz einfach
immer wieder runter aufs blech
so jetzt habe ich circa fünf minuten
lang geknetet und als nächstes geben wir
jetzt unsere kartoffeln mit dazu und das
gebe ich auch immer nach und nach dazu
und dann immer wieder die gleiche
technik verwenden denn dann bekommt ihr
wirklich einen schönen tag von mutti und
mutig von branchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das kneten nimmt einiges an zeit in
anspruch aber es lohnt sich
und ich hab jetzt die kartoffeln
komplett eingearbeitet und jetzt kommt
unser wasser in unsere mädels spiel beim
wasser müssen vorsichtig sein je nachdem
wie groß das alpha oder eben wie viel
kartoffeln ihr hattet braucht ihr nicht
so viel aber auch die ägypter wirklich
nur stückchenweise dazu so ein kleines
bisschen und dann vertretet ihr das
weiter und arbeitet jetzt zum schluss
das mehl unter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der teig ist jetzt komplett fertig also
insgesamt knetet man schon so 20 minuten
und jetzt können wir aber dafür sofort
weitermachen mit homers ganz kleine
auflaufform ein bisschen olivenöl und
dann zeige ich euch wie wir das in die
auflaufform geben
jetzt macht ihr euch eure auflaufform
ich schreibe euch mal meine maße in die
infobox es muss nicht genau die maße
haben aber so ungefähr
und jetzt geben wir zuallererst olivenöl
in die auch auf und sprechen dass
überall als am boden und an den seiten
richtig mit dem pinsel
jetzt mache ich mir zwischendurch immer
wieder die hände nass denn dann könnt
ihr das viel besser geklappt und ich
habe jetzt die hälfte des teigs auf den
boden gegeben und gibt dann noch etwas
vom teig am rand also ich ziehe den rand
richtig schön hoch und danach kam auch
schon die füllung eingeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und sobald die haftverschonung drin ist
fehlt eigentlich nur noch der deckel und
dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt immer wieder
etwas teig die könnte dann in den händen
schiff flach drücken und dann visum
puzzleteil also wie tetris quasi einfach
auf die oberfläche geben
[Musik]
also ich bin soweit ich habe jetzt die
oberfläche komplett bedeckt und was hast
du denn
aber in so probst an dich ich sage euch
auf einmal gab es ein video welches
dahin wir so das strebe draußen wir
haben wir mit acht stunden aufgegeben
es ist nicht aufgefallen aber wenigstens
ist sie das ist okay wenn ich mal kurz
weg und dann aber weiter so jetzt genau
jetzt aber mit nassen händen könnt ihr
eine oberfläche alles noch mal richtig
schön glatt streichen das auch keine
rillen zu sehen sind und als nächstes
brauchen wir wieder unser schönes gutes
olivenöl das geben wir jetzt hier einmal
auf die oberfläche also komplett
so verteile ich das nochmal so heute ist
richtig handarbeit hier mit sauberen
händen geht alles immer am schnellsten
und am besten
und als nächstes bevor ich das in den
vorgeheizten ofen gebe werde ich jetzt
schon mal die stücke schneiden
erstens hat es einfacher zu schneiden
und zweitens kann das olivenöl durch die
reden gelangen und kann noch mal alles
mit olivenöl befeuchten und schmeckt
sehr lecker abschluss genau jetzt
überlege ich habe mal trauten oder
vertrag oder also rufen wie halt nur
oder war 100 sich trauten also verraten
muss man es ein bisschen enger machen
aber mit ganz viel fantasie windes auch
rauten und jetzt kommt das in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze etwa 40 bis 45 minuten
bis eben alles schön durch ist alles
schön goldbraun ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und während euer ist dürfte jetzt im
ofen gegart könnt ihr euch um den rest
kümmern zum beispiel schon mal das
geschirr waschen schon erledigt genau
man hat er so viel zeit also 45 minuten
jetzt will ich gleich noch den salat und
dann ist pünktlich alles fertig und
genau die genauen mengenangaben die
schreibe ich euch natürlich wie immer
hier unten in die info box macht euch
ein screenshot geht einkaufen und dann
ran an den bullen wurden sehr guter
einwand man kann das ganze schon morgens
machen man kann das komplett vorbereiten
frischhaltefolie darauf geben und dann
45 minuten vor dem fastenbrechen ganz
einfach in den ofen schieben
also ist man dann nicht gestresst den
tag über kann sich um andere sachen
kümmern
das ist super drauf hat ihr noch mehr
welche rezepte sehen möchte die man auch
vor allem gut vorbereiten kann
dann schreibt sie noch gerne mal in die
kommentare dann kann ich auch sind
einschätzen was ihr noch sehen möchte
und genau dann wünsche ich euch jetzt
noch einen schönen abend schön
fastenbrechen guten appetit und markiert
mit dem hashtag description auf euren
fotos auf facebook und instagram bis zum
nächsten mal sorry
[Musik]
[Applaus]